that spell gets loose they're all coming  here  don't do this i have to try  exclusively in movie theaters thursday  all right parker you ready  [Music]  do it  exclusively at movie theaters thursday  look at this place and all the  possibilities  we need to send it back  i promise i'll fix this  you're not gonna take this away from me  exclusively in movie theaters thursday  spiderman is in fact peter parker  my entire life got screwed up  could you make it so that mysterio never  revealed my identity you ready  what just happened  when i shut that spell down we started  getting visitors looks like we got  competition  from every universe  i promise i'll fix this exclusively at  movie theaters december 17th rated pg-13  tickets on sale now dude  catch  tickets on sale now dude tickets on sale  now  dude  exclusively in movie theaters  you